hey Aaron Sampson's here guess what iron
Thompson did last week I'm Samson we
went to Montreal and it was like 20
degrees Fahrenheit over the people in
Montreal were so happy all right like
inner chest it's so warm outside yeah
getting a raise they were like running
with babies and strollers and like wow
we're just psyched it was 20 degrees
Fahrenheit I have two questions ask you
one did you have poutine who no I did
not okay too how was rainbow six siege
because you played that video game we
did it was so cold like my brain was
just kind of frozen no we didn't see
Rainbow six siege it was a it was like
red faction meets rainbow six so all
I've seen in the trailers is is it's
kind of seems a bit like counter-strike
kids folks inside of the house and then
a bunch of people that's one team and
then the outside team has to come in and
get them but then it's like it's almost
like like you said red faction a bad
company or were you just just walls
don't mean [ __ ] in this game dude it was
it was really cool it was the kind of
destruction that I've been waiting a
long time for I mean like literally you
know I mentioned red faction but like
there's literally a dude named sledge
with a sledgehammer it can slid his way
through walls but he can't bust apart an
entire airplane with it Red Faction
style there are certain areas that you
can bust through certain that you can't
something you can bust through but only
see through and not actually traverse
through like like floors and ceilings
you can break through but they're only
certain points that like a trapdoor will
form other times as you're looking
through floorboards so I okay what
answer the destruction he's referencing
is like yeah right in bad company 2 it
was common practice to like you see a
dude in the window you just blow out the
whole wall but this is a on a much more
micro level the kind of destruction
they're going for a point of like here's
the barricade I'm gonna melee out half
of this board and poke my gun throat do
you dudes who are coming down the way
yeah a lot of people are going to learn
the difference between cover and
concealment the hard way so most of the
stuff in this game is concealment
meaning people can shoot through it yes
it's not cover like you're vulnerable
anywhere in the house practically right
think one of the one of the gadgets on
the defensive side do name pulse has
heart rate monitor he can look up and
see you a floor above him and then just
unload on the ceiling and you'll be
walking around suddenly like rounds will
start coming through the floor and your
team will be freaking out you don't know
where it's coming from everybody what
kind of like back off he doesn't really
kill anybody but he messes up your game
like kind of breaks your confidence a
little bit and then your team has to
Reese trad Ajay maybe figure out how
you're going to get down to the hostage
and if you don't even if it's not him
you can shoot through the floor and the
team above like thinks that maybe
they're spotted or but it's maybe just
someone running around downstairs being
like I'll just messin with you guys like
the mental game and sort of these faints
and psych outs or I can be as powerful
as actually the Intel like you know that
they're there there's also like a really
strong sense of tension they've they put
together multiple mechanics so like it's
5v5 in the initial phase you go in with
your drones and you spot the other guys
and you know who's on the field there's
going to be I think they said 20 total
and I think we saw about half of them
but depending on who you spot like if
it's if it's smoke then you got to watch
out for like gas traps and if it's if
it's pulse you gotta watch a forgetting
spotting so how many different like so
you're picking specific characters for
each team then you of having it was 20
he said yes there's going to be 10 their
specific to their role so 10 attackers
and 10 defenders you're not going to
have the heart rate monitor on offense
right just like you're not going to have
the sledgehammer on defense so you know
you can't just be playing the same
character like on both sides because the
game alternates every match is a round
of attacking a round of defending around
of attacking around and all writing
first to four wins oh so it's instant
death counter-strike style and then
you're no respawns yet you just start
the match although that's incredible
that it's back and forth instead of
being like will do two and two and then
maybe swap it around for the fifth if
there ends up being one and it's good
because we were watching the Ubisoft
stream yesterday and the defenders were
winning the majority of the time okay
like their defense was strong the
attackers really I feel like it really
attack errs rely a lot more on
specifically coordinated plans as
opposed to sort of reactive defending or
maybe one person holding a checkpoint or
what have you but because you're playing
attack you're playing defend you're
playing soccer playing defend the game
was actually they were
very very close in wins right yeah so
that's sort of interesting to see how
it's going to play out because we asked
them when we were there how many times
is as hostage actually get rescue yeah
you know what are the numbers like
usually just end up killing everyone on
go to change an entire day that we were
there I think we saw the hostage get
rescued about three times okay was it
always a lady no you know it was a guy I
think most of the time okay the hostages
I think it was only a guy yeah yeah but
is just a MacGuffin though they should
make spelunky style words sometimes a
girl sometimes a guy and sometimes you
don't dog yeah you can't pick the
hostage up and throw them so that's
cocky I'm sure that that is actually
true if that was just like so oh you're
cuz we put the whole alpha version of it
is not a complete I don't know they're
there was a flying hostage Oh keep it in
keep it in here so yeah how long do the
rounds then have a good couple think
it's like and it was like three minutes
total in the build yeah you have 45
seconds to choose your character and
choose your spawn point as a team then
you have 30 seconds to as the attackers
roll your little drones around and see
everything and as the defenders are
bored things up and then the attacker
spawn and it's three minutes okay but
there are three minutes yeah the
attackers do so if the defenders survive
there yep okay if the defenders survive
in the hostage is not taken then the
attacker cuz and you'll see a lot of
times as time is ticking down like three
minutes doesn't sound all that short I
guess in terms of a round of a shooter
where like a few bullets is going to
kill you but I don't know if you're in a
boxing fight like just goes like that
but also you're trying to move
cautiously and go like lean Roger
corners you can burn time so easily or
you know they're like all right who's
gonna go with the front Oh should we
send some people around the back like if
you don't have your you're on point you
can easily is like get down to the wire
it's kind of like what they're trying to
do is make it like a real siege were
like if you're going to go in and get
the guys like unlike CS where you end up
having like one on each team just
running around the map looking for each
other on Italy like in this it's like
you need to go in I like get them all
real quick this is also where the
operator system comes into place so like
for what you know Chris and I walked up
to the door in the airplane and like put
breaching charge down and Chris put
another breaching charge down we're like
all right double bridge go you know
click
nothing happens will mute who's on the
defending team was sitting on the other
side with like a jammer no stops it from
exploding right so now you're your plan
screw you got goals yeah oh you can put
it down if you set it down and then go
away you don't have to be like standing
there like cranking you're like oh good
but you know now you've just lost 20
seconds with this whole plan you just
came up with that's a good chunk out of
your three minutes that you just like
screwed up yes is now you go to plan B
like ash fires a launcher and do it and
like blows it up and you go from there
so it's that's Robin well that clock
management that's that like strategy
back and forth you know and obviously
communication is super important and so
that's something that they talked about
like figuring out because obviously the
ideal is everyone's on chat we're all
talking yeah but you can't count on
players to want to do that so they're
talking about just they didn't talk
about the systems that they're putting
in place to sort of put communication in
there and you're non-vocal way but it's
gonna happen I think like if anything in
the past 12 months is reminded us stuff
like making a multiplayer shooter like
trying to get people to like pony up and
spend like fifty sixty dollars on the
game that we're titanfall and most
reasoning would evolve yeah can be
difficult and what what people tend to
criticize is like content a lot like
what are the things I can do so like
apart from this core game mode if they
alluded to like any other stuff that's
going to be going on to this yes so at
e3 last year they said that there was
gonna be a single player campaign or
mode was unclear feels gonna be like
more cinematic or how they were in a
structure yeah because it could be more
like old rainbow six or like even
towards vegas maybe yeah or it could be
just so they said they were gonna pull
supposedly pull terrorist hunt from
vegas which I know is it's very
requested it's like a co-op Matt
playthrough yeah I think they have
config confirm single-player and co-op
but not specifically what those will be
or what form they'll be but that's
actually something a lot of people were
asking about in the comments yeah on our
stuff is like is this multiplayer only
yeah cuz it is it is tough you know yeah
a lot of people I'm head of this field
because this is a like it's been a while
since Ubisoft to dip back into rainbow
six like Vegas to is so 2000 a 9 or 8 or
something so does it feel good like his
imagine this is the first time a bunch
of these you be self folk of like gone
back into the first person shooter
world obviously it's an alpha so it's
pretty early but like I did ahead of the
field you guys all of the mechanics I
thought were there again like building
that sense of tension with the the timer
and the like player versus player count
dad's and all that that was all there
the weapons feel pretty like standard I
didn't really bother me much just
because the gameplay was so good but
yeah I mean like it's pretty standard
Ubisoft shooting I'd say yeah you
wouldn't go in there and be like man
this farm us feels great yeah it's it
you can get a feel for what kind of gun
it is and what kind of like caliber
power it has but I wouldn't say any of
them were like fun to shoot but then
again it is alpha so that being said the
explosions were pretty crazy because
when on the defending team that you the
outside of whatever you were would be
breached and then you would hear these
rolling series of explosions yeah
getting closer and closer and closer to
your room oh my gosh and then you know
and then also the wall blows out in that
sense of like just a stove just a
ceiling yes also there's bullets coming
through a wall like an explosion isn't
just like boom there's a whole it's like
boom there's debris its scattered around
the room there's smoke in the air like
that it kind of hangs there there's like
stuff fluttering around like it can be
the visual aspect that's audio aspects
of this sort of mental game is it's
really cool that's excellent and it
presumably just a bunch of people firing
into the dust yeah yeah all right that's
nice pretty cool I have they alluded to
anything to do with like officer betas
or when is it coming out like is it
sometime this year it's currently
scheduled for fall of this year but
that's kind of one of those release
dates that yeah who knows they are they
have a beta announced that you can get
into for sure by pre-ordering but no
idea when that's going to be the closed
alpha version that we played and that
they showed on their stream it's there
they're going to be announcing the dates
for the closed alpha very very soon cool
and I think they're aiming to have it
pretty soon oh great uh and we may have
some codes to give away for that
depending on what comes our way but yeah
excellent sooo yeah that'll be cool if
we could get to play it up before you
three that'll be that'll be super
brilliant thank you very much
you